he get up very quick and you change your
game completely
a quick message from my brother khabib
that i want to share with one i want to
start off with the
with an ayah from the quran a hadith and
then close it up with some nasiha adhinu
nasiha
and the ayah that i want to reflect over
and
share with my brother is an ayah from
the quran in surah fusilla where god
almighty allah the creator is saying
woman
is
and who is better in speech allah is
saying than the one who
invites the one who calls to allah
to this deen who the one who does dawah
who shares because if i often you've
heard me say if you share
if you care you share so you share this
deen who is better than the one who
shares this deen
calls people to allah does righteous
good deeds and says i am of those who
have
bowed down who has submitted to my
creator in islam
and the hadith that i want to share with
you is a beautiful hadith subhanallah
where rasulullah is the last the final
messenger sent to mankind from muhammad
he said that
when the servant of allah of god
almighty mentions
allah to himself allah mentions you
allah
mentions him to himself and pay
attention to this
when the servant of allah mentions
a law in a gathering now stop right
there
be it on this channel that channel in
front of this person this interview
whatever the case now in front of the
world can you imagine now
the person's been given this opportunity
right all eyes on you
all the different channels all the
different interviews and now it's a
jihad it's a struggle it's a struggle
with oneself
a person kind of gets maybe a little bit
timid a little bit shy like you know
what people
what's this person what that person is
going to say but no when you reflect
over hadith
this hadith and you think like wow
when i mention allah in a gathering
allah will mention me
in a better gathering
we don't want to let these opportunities
go to waste and in closing my brother
habib let's try to make every
opportunity
a dow opportunity to the best of our
ability allah is testing us
we might not have another opportunity
like this
especially at this grandiose stage a
platform such as this
where you got the attention of the whole
world so can you imagine when you
reflect over that ayah from the quran
the hadith
this should be a motivation an
inspiration
a drawing towards the pleasure of allah
and this is
my piece of advice let's utilize this to
the best of our ability my brother
may allah give you victory and keep you
safe
and at the end after you come up from
making sajda shukr
and thanking allah god almighty allah
and you raise up and you point back
up to the created heavens and earth
inshallah we could do a breakdown of
that let them know that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the creator
that happens in the earth god almighty
allah